I'll do it all right this is where I die
yeah
ah what was that
noise Hello friends welcome to ROM
encounter the weekly show right here on
gamespot.com where me the Irish dude
plays a random video game on the
internet today's random video game one
of the many games I purchased during the
Steam Sale but one of the few that I've
actually played Rogue Legacy this game
came out uh 2013 last year uh celador
games and I had never played it up until
this weekend and I absolutely love it
let's hop right in uh for those of you
who don't know Rogue Legacy Hey look
it's it's a 2d hacken slash type thing
right how TR and boring could that
possibly be uh uh uh uh
uh but the uh the
USP as we call it in the business world
the unique setting point of this game uh
happens in in I
guess the way in which death works so
this as the title would suggest [__] is
a ro
like there's Perma death if I Get Smoked
by these guys I'm
done H that
chair uh it's procedurally generated as
well this is a really difficult first
level
um but what's different is the Legacy
part of the title which is that when you
die you basically create you pick what
sort of
uh traits
you want to take on with
the from your from your father basically
you're picking what child of this
dude you want to be and those traits
change up how you play the game some are
good so are bad sirly has been slain by
a
skeletone pretty bad job
Danny the game's not over s is there
then you get to pick what run of his
litter you want to be so here we got sir
Taco great name sir Cellar okay lady
Blair and on the right there you've got
some information about them
so we've a mage in the middle and then
two nights trait gay you are a fan of
the man so that probably won't change
much about the game also dyslexia You'
have trouble re riding things so that'll
probably mean that stuff in the game
world signs and whatnot will be uh
difficult to read which may or may not
matter and then you've all got a a
special spell as well this this fine
gentleman throws an axe in an
arc uh this dude summons a grand blade I
don't like that one too much also he's
color blind which means the game will
probably be black and white
um uh lady player here has no
traits low stats but can land
devastating criticals launches orb the B
every so I would say usually lady Blair
will probably be the one to go on this
one but for the sake of funniness I'm
going to go for our friend sir Taco here
the gay KN who throws an Axe and is
dtic uh you've also got this uh
wonderful Castle Manor with which you
can upgrade and get special abilities uh
so each time you play the game you've
got access to a bunch more
stuff like now I've got a Smithy so he
can Smith weapons for me uh you you got
to have to spend all the money you get
here because if you don't uh you
basically just hand it all to a stupid
ghost at the front of the castle so you
got to spend it all here or spend it
with our friend the smiy
here uh sadly I can't read what he's
saying so uh still on my without those
brups I can only make cruelty and Cotler
Cutlery please bring back
any is it blueprints I want to say you
find and I can bluid the most
amnesic equirement ever
ever out of Pricks of
coros you can make [__] make [__] happen
make [__] pop so yeah this is not a game
about completing it in one go or
anything like that this is a game about
putting in time and then using the sort
of uh best child possible to access the
various different areas of the castle
you want my money I must played it t
[__] is
that all right have all my money zero
gold home
di
building h yeah so uh this is also like
a portal thing so if you you can get
around the
uh there are various stages where there
are these fast travel locations
essentially and you can kind
of move between those also you're
encouraged to beat up everything that
you can
collect gold so the map right now is
there but if you look at the map above
us here there is a tower a forest and a
dungeon underneath I have not seen any
of these things cuz I'm terrible at this
game so let's see what
happens all right what's down below this
jerk so in the top right I've got my
health uh sorry top left underneath that
the blue bar is basically a special
ability bar thing so I think this guy's
ax in an
arc [__] darn goofed I'll do it again no
wrong way no wrong way there you go yeah
suck it down have another one
done H there's nothing in the mean oh
[__] there's nothing in terms of XP or
anything it's a it is predominantly a
loose based operation oh [__] so I
probably shouldn't have bothered hitting
this
guy came out of
him get downstairs oh [__] hate these
things oh my
dick
whoa whoa I'm close to
death there you go eat
that all right not doing too bad I'm
doing pretty bad actually I canot hit
those
freaking posters I used to play a game
called yojo on the Amiga which had
painting guys who would stab you as well
so I'm I've been I'm predisposed to
trying to murder those
things bam home a
dick so really at this stage I think the
most important thing is to collect as
much gold as
possible you I gold what's this
blueprint great that's my first Blood
plant I've
found so that's good but yeah I'm
primarily on a uh on a gold recovery
Endeavor here [__] chopping up all
this jewelry oh [__] oh [__] I'm out I'm
out I'm
out this guy ah
[__] Taco has been slain by FR
frosten oh well and his parting words is
purchasing equipment is cheaper and more
flexible than raising your base
stats I'll remember
that new
erir lady Priscilla is also gay I think
what happens as well is that you get you
get traits that persist down the
bloodline welcome to barville vertigo oh
yeah I've seen this
one we should just go for this one B
toggles freezing enemies on screen all
right I'm going to do
that I I'm lady Priscilla has gay
vertigo that makes it sound like it's a
disease that's weird Health up yes
please what else we got I've only got 50
gold
left I can't spend on anything that
means I'm going to have to give it to
the stupid ghost man oh Jesus Christ oh
that's that's some vertigo right there
Jesus okay uh
hey what's up blacksmith I found one of
your
blueprints oh [__]
uh a this is the
worst look at that one so my controls
are also upside down which is really
upsetting so I
need it's really confusing it means that
this one here I have to actually press I
I actually have to press up not not down
it's like oh [__] this all right
yeah I got to play line down on my head
upside you think all right let's give it
a
go well it is oh yeah that
works no it doesn't cuz left and right
is the the wrong way then that's even
worse all right take my money stupid
ghost man I don't know what the hell
that says but
okay even the loading screen is upside
down all right as long as I get my
gold I don't
care oh Jesus I'm out of
here look how much stuff is in this
room bam hom a
dick put the controller upside and you
kidding me I'm getting the [__] out look
at this room what look at this
nonsense I'm out of here I'm out of here
keep running oh for God's
sake part of me is happy that
happened oh my God what we got Lady
Sonia Sonia blade has hyper gonad ISM
you're perar roided attacks knock
enemies further also she has
Alzheimer's NOP not picking another one
of
you they are inbred they're hella bread
lady Teresa has a giant Axe and no
traits and she's got loads of Health
yep
actually one of you the family three
tree oh it's
there all right how much money we got 30
bucks great that's
useless you do it
Sonia take my
money I have AER my play through at home
does not have cross saving or steam
saving sadly oh
[__] oh Jesus I'm the
worst
o I love hitting
those uh [__] hey what's up ice
Golem MD oh
[__] can really
jump and up we go hey what's up what's
up bro what's going
on you
suck going to kill all you fools oh
oh damn
it over
there
oops oh [__] that no let's try over
here I just want as much gold as
possible so by means I have to destroy
all of the furniture and I'm okay with
that gold
me
chicken right gold gold gold gold
gold
uh uh uh
no all good here I still haven't used my
special
ability
[__] kill him before he gets his spell
off whoa what's going on over here oh
[__] eyeball thing
oh this thing
sucks die iBall th
ball look at all this money oh my God
330 I'm eating steak
tonight I love how they run she just
runs with the sword
just throwing it out there oh might be
money in that yep
money and everything in this
world right go away go away go away go
away Jesus you're
persistent all right there's a lot going
on here I feel like this is
dangerous oh
[__] is it even possible to I don't even
know no not going that
way ah
all right I'm guess I'm going down to
this area see what happens
here oh that's not
good got to time these right one no
[__]
dead I bury me with my
money Dodge shak's return trip in order
to maximize its
damage sorry lady
Teresa lady Jenny here launches orbs
that bounce everywhere is a dwarf
and on roids that's pretty good Quantum
translocator drops and teleports to your
Shadow
what throws a shock which comes back to
you you conduct electricity real well
weird uh no I'm going to go with this
one I want the quantum translocators
about boom all right let's spend some
money turns your knight into paladins
that sounds good let's do that press y
to block all uncommon damage that sounds
good
right 270 I feel like I should spend
some money on Smithy over here yo make
my make my sword
better
sure plus seven damage I can dig
it only got 20 cent left I give it to
the Ghost Boy
up
ghosty yes why you like rug Legacy cuz
it's like a good mix between the whole
pick up and
play nonsense of Rog likes with you know
a degree of permanency so you can you
can try and keep like you're
contributing to something bigger but
then necessarily having to put in
shitload of arrows uh uh
uh uh oh
[__] no I'm going over
here what's this ooh I should have
waited to use that one do I smell what's
up with the black
stuff where's my Quantum
translocator oh hello I can put it there
and then transport back here that's
pretty
cool wait also doesn't use that much uh
that much
power I hate these [__] shites get
away get away [__]
this out of
here my shadow
Powers now I need
health
who that's what's up
bringing my a game
here
yep great nothing at the end
wonderful thanks video
game go down to the sh
rights out of here out of
here all right there's only G I only got
one shot at this so I better not f it
up who effed it up
nope really hard on this
controller nailed it a you son of a
[__]
no
all right put my shadow
here TR it
again oh you piece of
anus sir skunky has been slain by a
spike tour even the spikes of names Sky
let you fly by pressing a in air all
right well I'm going to try and pick a p
a knight this time I guess we got a
barbarian Mage and a Nave great the one
time I won a KN there's
none trait irritable Bell syndrome even
the most Valiant Heroes can suffer from
irritable Bells all right spell
conflux I can see in
3d with lady
shaona but I weak
limbs or I could be a
dwarf with few issues
okay I want to see what the you can see
in 3d you can't see in
3d all right see what that's
about I got no money that time last time
let's give it all to the
dude take my
money wasn't in 3D to begin with so I
don't know what the difference is going
to going to
be powerock scrolling still happening
too so I don't
know left my
money oh
man oh hello
jukebox
yeah
the castle needs a
jukebox
HH [__]
eyeball suck I killed your brother he he
was way
better
[__]
on
everyone uhoh
uhoh hey what's
up I
win all that gold 190 baby blue Prince
ni just PL
get what else we got to discover in here
all those chandeliers there's no
chandeliers left in this castle by the
time I'm done
hello money money money making a
rain [__] yeah look at this
nonsense a mystical door you know that
bets behind there they're giving me Mana
and health it's probably a boss fight
see if there's anything else I can
get I can teleport back to the other
part that's
cool more
Mana oh
[__] well I'm out of here I'm out of
here [__] all right so that's definitely
a harder part of the game I'm going to
go for this
guy oh [__] it's a
boss and I have no
Health Kinder Surprise uh uh Jesus oh
[__]
this
nope oh damn you learn the nuances of
your spell to maximize their
potential think I got to put in more
arrows before I can kill that thing all
right we got a paladin
here you're skinny so every hit sends
you
flying near
sighted the irony being is you remember
things with extreme
clarity
got my Quantum one there tra glaucoma oh
that's
amazing I'm going to go with a I'm going
to go with py over
here spend all my
money upgrade my health
again else we
got yeah Health why
not base
traits and maybe equip I feel like
equipment is a better shout though I can
block now as well cuz I'm a
paladin let's see if I can get any sweet
armor what is this Squire Helm hell
yeah think equipment is where it's
at 525 wow look at all the extra armor
it gives you 525 man so that's a pain
you can't hold on to this I got to spend
all this
money that adds Five magic and adds
weight as well I don't want
that
do I want extra magic I guess I do want
more
magic what else there
cloaks pretty good how else in the
manner 250 what'll 250 in the manner get
me 90 Mana up
Yep this guy 100
gold equip
up I don't really need that at the
moment I'm not spending much on
that more Mana again why
not all
right feeling healthier got more Mana
you can have 20 throw this guy 20 gold
whatevers now I got my sweet
block am super skinny that's pretty good
I wish I was super
skinny
lock
oh so the block gets rid of uh Mana I
guess sucks but
whatever
downstairs way stronger than the other
one money money
money
F chicken baby oh that
chicken feel like I'm getting a little
bit
better very chest damage fairy chest
objective take no
damage okay I'll try to take no damage
that's just just in that area it's just
here it's upstairs oh
sugar whoa
no damn it I took damage I I supposed to
get the hell out of here this is a
pain oh
[__] all right no fairy chest for me I
guess can I come back and do it again
no oh this bit I remember this bit
ah [__]
[__] what the hell don't [__] your pants
why is the guy from don't [__] your
pants here did they make that as
well H
uh they don't you [__] your pants next
time got
furniture and
statues feel like every time there one
of these things it's cuz there's a boss
coming up oh Jesus yeah oh [__] that I'm
out of there you kidding me
ah I want more
money go to the dungeon some other time
hey what's up bro nice job not [__]
your
pants
[__] over
here
oh
Jesus one of those is for
serious he
spikes oh God damn
it bury me with my
money lady Jenny by the guard box
2000 who else we got here trait the bald
and the Beautiful baldness all right
80 HD pretty
good lady Stephanie here is God this
lety
again giant axe I like the
palles I got ADHD so
I got more I got more speed I like
that sure doing it now yeah cool all
right we're gonna go to a little ad
break GNA take a little bit of a load
off see if I can do a bit of DIY to
my my sweet manner here so we'll be back
in just a
moment welcome back to random cander
we're playing Rogue Legacy um I just put
some money into the equip up um area
because it unlocks you can get these
extra Wings the enchantress basically
gives you magic upgrades all the Smith
but I've never gone for the the
architect so I'm going to go for the
architect this time see what
happens boom I can lock down the
castle
interesting we'll talk to him outside in
a second can I spend any more this 60 60
Gold can I get rid of you somewhere no
pain in the ass all right where's
where's my architect boy here we are
what's
up greetings
boy I want to know cool fact he's
crazy you can prevent the castle from
changing this way you can go through
exactly what your ancestors went through
impressed you should be head I bu this
fantastic Contraption with science and
Magic
most 40% of all the gold I
earn man all right let's see what
happens
okay so this is going to put it back to
to what my ancestors saw so I'm guessing
this is like the default way to play it
then guessing every time you do
that it's this way I also love that
she's got this little Dicky bow and 8 HD
so she runs twice as fast as everyone
else
Dam this exact same as it was first time
maybe
up uh uh oh was the same as last time
okay that's pretty
cool you can kind of Bank on stuff
second time around I'm going to try and
remember all the gold was I got last
time [__]
[__]
H give me that gold you're next
boy yummy I wouldn't usually eat meat
from a zombie
but oh
[__] eat
this
we good there's another one over here
remember where was the money oh here we
go fairy chest
again ah you stupid video
game how am I supposed to I
know got to be super quick on that last
bit God damn it God damn
it where was all that money was it
Daniel don't [__] your pants dude
maybe not I'm going to go to the other
side mix it
up oh
[__]
ah I get more [__]
blueprints a bunch of gold as well
chicken Mana yeah oh what the hell it's
a
forest It's A rad
spooky
[__] mushrooms got
it I'm hoping these harder areas have
harder have more gold in the M I'm
really OD about the
gold oh
[__]
this is really
creepy headless horse
sure oh
spikes this game gets pretty
hard go back to the other side of the
castle oh Jesus this just gets more
intense every single
time
yep
yep terrified absolutely terrified at
everything that's happening
there this looks
safe I really wish I could get that
chest oh back here
again this funny run I just remembered
I'm only going to get 60% of this sweet
XP
that's oh
[__] I get that chandelier that's all
228 and 60% a lot of gold
over
here
no oh for God's
sake my ball even not
gold man I've ran into like five
different types of areas here what are
you yeah sure I'll
pray I got a
compass great what are you pointing me
towards gold I
hope up do it again do it again do it
again I'll hit you
son
again
a damn you
iine look at all those things I killed I
murdered loads that time that was great
I'm getting less terrible at this I'm
sure sir jarvin the Paladin he's got
roids Fire's daggers pretty
good a ton of visual no peripheral
vision
all right I'm going to go with this guy
just to mix it
up
294 all right I feel like I want to pour
all this money into into this
dude 350 God damn
it extra
magic not sure why the mate matters that
much
but what else can I do
here General attack goes up that's
pretty good I'll spend money on
that upgrade
barbarian
barbarian actually let's get the lady
where's the enchant
enchantress 130 what would that leave me
with 160 could I still afford that
NOP
let's get anyway just for fun just for
shits and giggles as
they
damn hey what's up entr
tranches I can't read what you're saying
cuz I'm dyslectic again but
whatever 175 so close so this gives you
different special abilities and stuff
none of which I can afford at the moment
which
is so
irritating can't spend anything on
anything can
I God damn it let's going to give this
stupid ghost
thing stupid ghost man all of my money
uh uh
uh
irritating weight is important the items
get heavy good point
magnall I haven't gotten that far
yet how's that
thing how many eyeballs are
here
oh I've got a shadow
thing that's one of my favorites I'm
guessing it doesn't persist into
different
areas let's
see
nope [__] [__] this
[__]
sh the gold I'm waiting for one of those
things to turn into a
body all right back down to the
crazy terrible world oh
Jesus
[__] wow okay right I'm going to try
it I'm going to try
it oh you can jump on those
things stupid lady Henrietta you suck
also I suck next up doesn't matter I got
so many children look how many people
look how many generations we've already
gone
past it's like 400 years of people
trying to invade this
Castle actually they're probably all
about 15 by the time they get sent into
the castle so I don't know maybe it's
like 100
years your heavy enemies can't knock you
back I'm also
blind color blind sorry not
blind sure I'll go for the blind Nave
why not call a blind
Nave 90 absolutely useless all right
whatever yeah call call her
blind it's also a lady I didn't think
you were able to get call blind a lady
but I had a lecture in college who was
the lady who was callor
by not any of those red green ones just
this one straight up no
color
ah all this gold I'm
getting black and white
gold rid of that bad
boy Dam you doom Bass
takes a little bit getting used to the
the reach on this
sword more than I would have
thought hey what's up
Jesus eat daggers of here on my
own [__]
on die die
die don't change your pattern don't
change your pattern God damn
it
ah deeply depressing not because she's
dead but because I have to back to the
start tunnel vision no peripheral vision
sure let's see what that one does I'm
also the one apparently
there's a matrix reference there I'm not
really sure
why also
upgrades 150 150 is absolutely
useless type of economy is this what
the whoa I can jump pretty high have all
my money stupid
thing right okay I'm the one got
it I see the world for what it is
this is the
Matrix hit you on the head
idiot turn
around draing all your Cutlery and
tables and
stuff
hey what's up try that again yeah you
[__] a
dick is that going to hurt me am might
instantly going to hurt myself by doing
this eat that eat that as
well please be full of
money
yes I die here aren
I
[__] ax jump is higher than I
think
[__]
[__] it's on a sweet
book journal entry treason an assassin
is wound of my father the king being
ordered back to the kingdom he sent my
siblings in line a quest to save him
together we will venture into the cursed
woods and enter Castle
hamster wait isn't this me let Cur
Castle SL the edge of the cliffs blah
blah blah blah blah blah
great money money money look at this
stuff wow look at all that money this is
the best
550 am I fighting that big thing again
cuz I'd really like not to be because I
haven't got that much health
ah
[__] hey Kinder Kinder
Bueno that's taking nothing off you
yeah that gu are real son of a
[__] I'm going to spend all my money
what else we got though peroid no no way
am I going for another
vertigo tunnel
vision kind knock me back it's pretty
good all right I'm going to go P here s
Scorpio got my block as well
560 what can I purchase for
that perhaps some sort of wonderful
armor [__] yeah I can 520 look at that
16 armor
bam you can have your 35
gold stupid
dude I'm starting to get heavy now
that's probably going to probably going
to
matter jump ridiculously high so I don't
know money money
money
right [__]
timing is amazing [__] all this
stuff
nope I'll try this
way ah you suck you can't go through the
firewall oh got there for some
reason oh
[__]
climbing down
whoa worthless
okay hey what's up guys I didn't mean it
earlier you guys are all right see
you oh you kidding me am I really do I
have to go this
way God damn
it
oh
[__] I'll do it all right this is where
I
die
y
ah least I spent all my money on sweet
armor that I can pass down to my child
somehow cognitional insensi to pain no
no pain what does that mean does that
mean I just when I get hit I don't got
bounced back that's pretty
good look at the size of this dude lady
Paladin as
well yeah I'm going with I'm going for
lady Blair here Tony Blair's wife 90
gold crit crit crit
crit definitely not trying to get the
same castle as last time how
much that chair no gold this time chair
all right screw
you
[__]
nope I just keep farming this [__] for
gold oh I missed the gold that time damn
it I need that chicken see you jerks I'm
out of
here oh that's [__] why didn't turn
right at the last
second I care about his
money oh I gu
jerk
ah H whoa not cool bro give me that
money Bam
Bam who I did not see you
dudes W who who it's not going
good now I'm
boned
yep one glow it's been a bad couple of
runs
here sir
dude OCD dwarf yep sounds
good
310 look at all that
money let's upgrade a spell hey it
really is a small dude all
right
Sprint gain a PA to dash short distances
LT or or to
dash oh sweet yeah that's cool that's
going to be handy I can do it midair as
well take my
money all right OCD dwarf let's do
this
what wait getting extra for destroying
stuff really is that the OCD trade
that's pretty cool oh I'm so hard to hit
F fall you guys I'm going to get this
sweet gold down here screw
you trying hit me I'm a tiny dwarf thing
oh this is great this dwarf is
op uh
uh take the world on with this
guy
lady
oh what the
[__] all right Scythe let's do
it right mothers which one you want I
got your gold I don't need to kill you
anymore but I
will
oh right
dwarf is just murdering
fools here
again
yeah be
dwarf
you doom
boss dwarf is killing it this is
great that's sweet MP I'm getting
back suck it
down taking a fight to them there look
at
this
your bone I hit you with my
bone
[__] uh
hmd God damn
it one bad thing about being a
dwarf a money bags 570 man I'm raking it
in
later give me all my energy back [__]
yeah op
dwarf
right keep making a rain bones I'm going
to come get
you
[__] this one dude you kidding
me all that money I don't care if I die
yeah I at a 780 this is
ridiculous more chicken someone give me
chicken a
chicken oh man look at
this fuing chest plates and everything
and money and look at 82
920 breaking it
in
over a
grand oh that sweet
MP oh it's getting getting a bit
worrying
here Bing out I'm bouncing
out more chicken got some chicken over
here
oh I don't like it up
there
scary go back to the start
but I don't want to kill this
jerk
yes
this money money money 1,000
wonders there a place down here I didn't
go
to all
this didn't attack was this bam break it
in that
gold all right I'm going to go upstairs
see what happens
[__] money
man look at this thing I'm getting the
hell out of here oh
[__] ah great run what a run sir
Lancelot you op dwarf you are the
man look at all that
money I'm I'm always going for Dwarfs
now on look at this dude how are you his
son that's
ridiculous gigantic ISM sure let's go
for that see what
happens all right look at all this
money I don't even know what to spend it
on I'm going to go straight to these
dudes CU they seem to have all the cool
stuff what else we
got grants the power to jump in the air
I already have that grants you the power
to jump in oh double jump is that what
that is do
it no more all right see what else we
got
here blood
chest minus Health
vampirism I don't even
know minus 16 I'm all
right more
magic adds more waste I guess I've only
got limited amount of weight I can
use spend the rest on the manor I
think we got
here have I not upgraded night already
I upgrade barbarian barbarian king press
y to do an epic shout
sure faroh farro D all
right unlock
Shinobi
yep [__] Shinobi super fast super
deadly Warrior can I throw
shurikens and I've got zero that's great
don't have to give any to this
jerk H yeah yeah you L it yourself you
didn't give you any
money
ganism all right can you follow in your
daddy's footsteps and be op gigantic man
I'm going to say nope in
immediately I think you're going to
die yep just [__] book it
yep yep great great nice work sir maze
you spent all the family gold and
immediately
died I think that's it I think that's it
I think op dwarf is where it was
at thank you very much for watching as
ever thank video Know Dan JN everyone in
the back for hooking this all up making
it so easy to play Rogue Legacy is good
fun I like it a lot uh if you have any
suggestions as ever for random encounter
Danny owire on Twitter I think next week
going to
do uh Next Car Game the tech demo stuff
because that was that was good fun
played some of that over the weekend I
have so many games from the Steam Sale
that I hadn't played um that I have to
make my way through so might just burn
through those for a while but yeah if
you have any suggestions let me know
otherwise plenty more live programming
here on gamespot.com
including now playing it two in which we
are
playing Rob Zombies monsters and robots
three for the price of one tune in then
make sure you subscribe on Twitch keep
it on gamespot.com and see you guys next
time
adios